انها المياه هو الصراع على مواردها وبحاله
سد النهضه من صدودها الى مصبها نزاعات
المياه اصبحت سمه القرن الحالي الملء
الرابع لسد النهضه بات وشيكا في اثيوبيا
مصر غير راضيه وهي التي لوحت اكثر من مره
باكثر من خيار تحاول القاهره مجددا اللجوء
الى مجلس الامن الذي ناء بنفسه سابقا
واحال الازمه الى الوساطه الافريقيه التي
لم تفلح في دفع اثيوبيا الى تغيير موقفها
اليوم اثيوبيا ورغم الرفض المصري
والسوداني ماضيه في تعبئه تضمن الملا
الرابع وتعرب عن استيائها من قرار جامعه
الدول العربيه بادراج ملف سد النهضه كمندن
دائم في مجلس الجامعه وزير الخارجيه
المصري سامح شكري دعاها بدوره للتحلي
بالمسؤوليه مع التجديد على ان بلاده ستضمن
حقوقها